today I'm here to talk about you know
building an ml experimentation platform
for easy reproducibility and if since
you're all here and you are you know
experienced in the mlop side of things
you know how important you know
reproducibility of ml experiments is and
what are the challenges that are
involved and we're gonna you know see
some of them and also address how some
of these envelopes challenges especially
around reproducibility can be solved by
using Lake fs and how can you go about
building an experimentation platform
after this
and I'm V now and I currently work as a
developer advocate for lakefest and as
you can see here I started as a software
engineer and then eventually moved on to
the data and ml side of things work that
has you know worked at Nike apple and
other companies before I landed at Lake
FS where I'm currently now working as a
developer Advocate and as I as it shows
I'm an open source contributor and I
write to you know I like to talk about
the data engineering and the mlops best
practices the things that I've learned
and the things that I'm still learning
about because it's never really ending
as you all probably know better
and yeah so let's Jump Right In enough
about me
this is something that we've all seen
especially in the envelope space right
because literally when you are talking
about training an ml model at scale or
whatever scale it may be the ml code or
the actual training job is literally the
probably five percent of the whole you
know
Avenue of things that one has to do like
starting with data collection when you
have different data sources each of them
you know sending in data with different
schemas and whatnot and then
most of the envelope's problems are not
necessarily machine learning problems
they are data problems so that is why
there are parallels being drawn between
data engineering and ml Ops because if
you solve the data engineering problems
you're almost always solving relative ml
Ops engineering problems too
and of course as you can see here it it
is not just about the ml code there is
like a bunch of data problems around
that needs to work
and to kind of dive deep into and look
at the the flow of what an ml
experimentation or just an ml ops world
looks like of course it starts with
multiple data sources where we get our
you know raw data from and then you go
about curate curating the data depending
on whatever your use case may be or
whatever your ml model you're building
for and then feature stores of course
because now
it's not always you know advisable to go
back to Raw training data every time
because we have like different ml use
cases and sometimes all of us are
working with the same training data
which means that it's good to have these
reusable features that multiple teams
and multiple ml models can use instead
of just duplicating it every time so we
went one step further to use a feature
store and the next one is of course
feature retrieval in terms of depending
again depending on if you're working on
a recommendation system or a search
engine
the feature retrieval might differ and
also even if it is not a recommendation
or a search engine a model that you're
building feature selection methods are
something that we always play around
with and you need to have that mechanism
as well and validating the features and
eventually comes the model training part
of it and then validating the model and
tuning the hyper parameters and whatnot
and eventually serve the model and keep
it in a registry as well so we can come
back at a later point in time to see
you know how the history of models were
so like what were the history of models
that was served at different point in
time now all of this looks very linear
but then if there is one thing that we
know how ml Ops is different from
software engineering it is that software
engineering and the software development
is very linear whereas mlops is not we
move back and forth all the time
starting from data cleaning and data
pre-processing we try out different data
preprocessing methods different features
selection methods and even like you know
handcraft different features and then
again use different ml models to train
and eventually see if this is all making
sense and if not you always come back
and play around with different variables
including hyper parameters so it is
always to and fro and back and forth
because of this incremental and
iterative nature of you know ml
development
although this one looks very linear
there are like steps that are you know
interchangeable and they do go back and
forth and to accommodate this different
nature of ml is why we need an
experimentation platform that will
enable us to do this so you can deliver
ml development at a higher velocity as
we are doing with software development
now
these are not by any means the
exhaustive list of challenges in ml Ops
but these are some of the challenges
that I have experienced and people who I
speak with experience on a regular basis
like having an ml experimentation
infrastructure like we just talked about
just to make sure
we can develop at the same velocity
as the software engineering World
Without You Know hindering us like the
availability of tools and the
availability of infrastructure should
not hinder us from making progress when
it comes to ml development
and the second is of course like you
know
the crisis of reproducibility I'm not
sure if it applies to all of these
industries but most of these people most
of the people that I spoke to from
Pharma and fintech for example they have
very strict regulations on when they can
use specific models for example if
somebody is using an ml model or AI to
actually diagnose cancer
now you want to make sure that ml model
is reliable and trustworthy right so
the way that you can actually reproduce
a specific model after a training you
should be able to do that at any point
in time if there is an audit from NFTA
for example you should be able to do
that at any point in time so crisis of
reproducibility is more pronounced in
certain industries and not so much
probably in ad and you know other
serving Industries but that's one of the
biggest challenges of you know having a
solid ml experimentation platform and
explainability of course and I think
explainability and trustworthiness of ml
models kind of go hand in hand and
thanks to neural networks and you know
further development of models like we've
kind of lost them to Black Box setup and
so even though it is you know still
Black Box models the ability to still
arrive at the same set of models
irrespective of how many ever number of
iterations of trainings you go through
is still important again that is one of
the challenges that is still not
resolved as well
and another interesting thing that I've
also experienced in my past is that you
know having this ownership around data
and feature so if there is a different
team that is responsible for you know or
who who owns that specific training data
and you use that data to go around build
some features and models and at some
point in time if you think oh you know
what I want to go back and create new
set of features and see how my model is
going to look but by the time you go
back to create these new features that
training data that you use is not going
to be there
you know it probably got updated and you
know aggregated you don't know because
the ownership of the data is in the
other team and now suddenly you will not
be able to create new features on the
same set of data and the minute you lose
the same set of data you have nothing to
compare the models against they are not
like you know Apples to Apples
comparison anymore and it's not again
possible to go back to that specific
iteration of the model
and I guess it's the lineage problem is
again like not very specific to ml I
think it's like data lineage in general
is a big problem when we try to go back
to who changed this data where is this
data coming from and going back all the
way to the raw source of data
and collaboration I think of all these
problems collaboration is probably like
the least tricky of the solutions here
of the challenges here because you know
working in teams I think we've to some
extent mastered it but one challenge
though is
because it is ml training set and if it
is it is not as big we're not working
with petabytes of data to train an ml
model at best we're talking about a few
terabytes of data so because of this
nature somehow we were okay to copy the
data across multiple buckets and across
multiple teams and collaboration is not
happening the way it is happening in
software engineering we don't use git
for example or for the data side of
things like the data versioning for
collaboration in general is not as
prevalent
and the other problem is of course
version controlling all of these ml
assets you know together atomically and
this is a very interesting thing because
we do have a lot of tools today in the
mlop space that can version you know
data and the code and the models and the
assets for us but somehow we don't have
one tool that can version all of these
together for us
most of these tools leave out the data
component and version everything else
and we have experiment tracking and
model monitoring and everything else but
again the minute you start going back to
the original training data on which you
created the features and training the
models it would all like you know start
breaking apart because there is no one
way of actually versioning all of these
components together
now
again as we saw we have plenty of tools
despite you know all the challenges that
we still have despite all these tools we
still have all these challenges right
it's like look at this we have so many
end-to-end tools and data Centric tools
that will that at least promise US that
it can do
versioning of all these components but
still today we're here talking about
those challenges all over again which
means I guess those Solutions are very
fragmented and we don't have an
end-to-end infrastructure for ML
experimentation
and now
just you know getting started with
one issue the first the top most and the
prioritized one is the ml
experimentation side of things and I
these points are almost covered here
I've done like you know like they've
talked about the iterative nature of
development how it is you know to and
fro and again ensuring data consistency
in terms of when I run a model training
today and if I run a model training
tomorrow on the same set of data and the
parameters will I even have access to
the same set of data and parameters and
the conflicts to be able to arrive at
the same model do we even have the
consistency to
do that and only if you have that
consistency will you be able to trust
your ml pipeline right so it's all very
interlinked to each other
and again like compliance to regulations
because in certain industries the
regulations are very constraining and
you need a way to do this very
effectively as well
and again reproducibility and
explainably it's like all these
challenges when I talk about it like we
all understand these challenges and
we've all come across these challenges
some of us even worked with these
challenges in the past or even currently
let's just
you know move on from here and see what
actually can be done from this like we
understand these challenges what now
here is where Lake FS comes in remember
how we talked about this whole process
of starting from raw data all the way to
serving your model and monitoring it
you can use lakefest if you use lakefest
for your experimentation platform you
will be able to version everything
including the data you know the features
and the model and the metrics including
the artifacts of it together
at one place which would be your
lakefest Repository
and just to give you an idea of how
would it look
here for example as you can see lakefest
offers git like branching so when you
are experimenting with Git like branches
for example you can imagine having your
training data set in your main branch or
say that is your production Branch for
example and for every iteration of your
ml experiment that you're running you
simply want to Branch out and then run
your experiments in that specific Branch
so you can go ahead and create as many
you know branches as you want as many
experiments as you want to run
now at the end of it though
you can vary all these parameters and in
each of these branches you will have all
these components right the code data raw
data preprocessed data features and like
you know model artifacts metrics configs
everything in each of these branches by
themselves
and at the end of it you can even
compare these models for their
performance and say hey whichever model
is a winning model for example based on
F1 score I would want to merge only that
Branch to production which means I'm
going to push only that I'm going to
deploy only that model to production
you know to serve my customers
internally
and just by having this you know git
like branching for your experimentation
platform you will be able to
achieve almost you know an end-to-end
data versioning capability for your
envelopes
now like how can you do that and where
does even lakefest sit with your
existing set of tools
as you can see here lakefs essentially
gives you git for data right it sits on
top of these object stores or any of
these data Lakes be you know if you're
with AWS then I would start with AWS S3
or GCS or Azure blob or even if it is an
on-prem object store like Min IO for
example lakefest sits on top of any of
these object stores and it offers git
like interface what it means is that if
suppose if you have your trading data
sitting in an S3 bucket all you need to
do is you know have Lake FS create a
repository on that S3 bucket this is
just like a git repository now now you
can go ahead and create a new Branch out
of this repository and work with the
data in this new Branch without actually
affecting your production data or the
actual you know training data that is
living in production now in this new
branch that you created you can you know
commit the data at different instances
for example in every step of the ml
training right when we curated the data
when we created new features or when we
were training the models when we were
storing these artifacts you can take
commits at each of these steps and at
the end of it you can either choose to
merge it or just delete the experiment
if it didn't you know turn out to be as
fruitful as you thought it would now the
existing host of applications that you
currently use to train your ml models
you know be tensorflow spark and Sage
maker and carers and whatnot all of
these packages can access Lake FS
the same way it accesses S3 so if you
already are using any application that
is using the data in S3 to do the ml
training it would work asses on Lake FSS
bar so with minimal intervention in your
existing code you will be able to do
this and the one on the right side is
just you know
a very visual representation of that as
you can see if your S3 you know the
training data is in a specific S3 path
the new only new change would be just
you know adding the name of the branch
to that existing path and that would be
it for you to actually go ahead and
train the model
now
when I say that you can just create a
new Branch every time is it like copying
the data again then if it is copying the
data what is the point right this was
the problem we set out to solve
this can be explained because lakefest
does not necessarily copy the data when
you create a new Branch out of you know
a main branch for example what it does
is it only copies the pointers to these
objects underneath so all of these
object references are being copied when
you create a new branch
so Branch creation operation is only a
few milliseconds so even if you do have
like you know terabytes and few
petabytes or even few hundred petabytes
of data you would still be able to you
know create a new Branch for an isolated
experiment environment in a few
milliseconds so there is no delay in
that as well and currently to you know
give you an idea of the scale of things
we have a couple of customers like
Toyota and Volvo and Lockheed Martin who
are using about 100 no 10 to 12
petabytes of data without any you know
scale restrictions at all
and because of this and you can also see
that you know suppose if the data has
changed suppose if you deleted a
particular column and say hey I don't
want this column and I don't want this
feature to be used in my ml model and
the next time you do a commit it is
gonna you know update its object
reference again if you go about creating
more features because we tend to create
you know additional features from the
existing training data it is going to
create new object references to the
added data but the common data the
common objects would have like you know
shared object references and only the
new data would get you know written back
meaning like FS does copy on right
anytime a new data is getting added to
it
now
I guess enough about Lake FS let's go
ahead and see how it can actually do the
experimentation side of things right
like we just talked about you can have
all of your training data live in your
main branch and in the experiment Branch
for example you simply Branch out and
start running your ml experiment and you
can have tags at different points of
these experiment to say you know when
was this trained or add any other
metadata that you want to be able to
reproduce it or to be able to reference
it later essentially
and it can include you know hyper
parameters training URL and infra URL
and whatnot or some of in some of these
cases you may even want to add the model
artifacts because they can also be like
read later
and unlocking collaboration was the
second one and
just to give you a very high level
overview of you know how one can use
lakefest for unlocking collaboration
it's similar to git like I said again
and you can have different people work
on the same you know ml training data by
simply branching out another interesting
thing that I may want to add here is
that lakefest also has role-based access
control which means you can choose you
know which teams or which team members
would have access to what kind of
branches or what you know specific
prefixes of data that you already have
so this way you are making sure there is
data governance in place and you're not
exposing your data to all of the
organization as well
and in addition it also supports Branch
protection rules just like in get so for
example if you say I don't want any
parquet files in my prod or I don't want
anybody to merge data into you know
production Branch directly you would be
able to configure that as well
and now to the most important part how
one can go ahead and Version Control all
of these ml assets right
which is again
by branching you will be able to do all
of this but then the most important
thing is how it can also include the
training data not just the models and
the metrics that every other tool also
does
and as in the demo that I will show I
would talk about how you can actually
version all of these together including
you know the raw data preprocessed data
features and everything
together
and yeah
this is pretty much about you know what
lake FS can do for the ml
experimentation and if you are
interested like again like FS is like an
infrastructure that would give you
this uh features that you can build on
top of
based on what your requirements may be
for an ml experimentation platform
and now
when you are using lakefest there are
like different kind of use cases one can
think about like for example if you want
to experiment in isolation which we just
talked about it's like create a branch
and you're good to go and if you want to
create a tag this is specifically around
reproducibility so you can create any
tags like you know how we create release
tags and get for different you know
versions
these tags would help you go back to a
specific iteration so you could just
check out that tag and you have
everything ready for you
and reproduce of course like refer to
the specific tag and you're able to
reproduce and reprocess and undo a
change like just like it you will be
able to do the merge and re you know
revert as well now let's quickly dive
into the demo and in the demo I have an
ml experiment running I have used the
wide quality data set and what I'm
trying to do is like a simple
experimentation which is like in
experiment one branch I'm gonna try a
couple of features and then use the
different you know classifying model and
then in experiment two again I will
create different set of features and I
will use the different algorithm and
then in the end I'll compare the
performance of both the both of these
models and whichever is the winning
model I'll just you know push it into
production meaning I will merge it into
the main branch
and in the end I'll also show you how to
create a tag and reproduce a specific
iteration of the experiment as well so
let's Dive In
okay so this is our lakefest URI looks
and another thing that I want to mention
is that lakefest has you know a URL it
also has a lake CTL command line utility
if you're you know the CLI person and it
also has different API clients if you're
a python spark Scala Java user you know
depending on whoever whichever language
you're comfortable with you can play
around with that as well and this is how
the
the UI looks
um
okay so I'm just trying to create a new
like FS repository and to create a
repository I would need a bucket
underneath as well where my data is
residing and I am not I've not used S3
here I'm just using Min IO because you
know any S3 compatible Object Store like
FS can work with
and I'm just creating a new minio bucket
in here
so it currently has you know no data
it's all empty and now let's go ahead
and create a new Repository
over that is the S3 bucket or the minio
bucket we just created
as you can see no one committed changes
there is only main branch no tags at the
moment
so now I have configured a jupyter
notebook because I'm a python user so
I'm going to use Python API client to
you know run my ml experimentation and
also to you know talk to The lakefs
Underneath just a bunch of you know
installations and dependencies and input
statements and then I'm configuring it
with you know access and the secret keys
and whatnot
and now
we've already seen how to create a
lakefest repository and minario bucket
so we are good
okay
so here I'm going to treat the main
branch as my production Branch so I'm
not going to put everything and anything
into mine and ingest data is the landing
Zone where I get my you know my ml
training data or the raw data from these
different sources
and so I have currently two branches and
as you can see the you know commit
hashes for both of these branches are
the same what I mean by that is because
we created because these two branches
share the same set of pointers of course
there's commit hashes are the same
and let's go ahead and upload the wine
quality data set into our ingest Branch
some you know trying to simulate how our
data sources will push the data into our
Landing Zone
cool so we have the today's date
partition CSV file and in the
uncommitted changes we can see you know
what what are the files that got added
as well
just a quick
overview of you know how to see the
number of files that got changed
and once I committed of course you can
see it in the comment that what are the
files that got updated in this specific
comment
and yeah so this is just a you know a
little bit of data exploration that we
all do just to understand what the data
looks like and what are these you know
what are each of these columns and
features like
um
and another interesting thing is that
lakefest UI also has duck DB embedded it
comes with it so if you are using pandas
and if the scale is not as much you
don't even need to get started with
spark for example you could just like
use duct TV to query and like you know
do the data exploration side of things
and pandas to run your you know data
cleaning pre-processing and Escalon or
whatever tool that you would use to
actually train the models
[Music]
all right okay so we're waiting for the
plot to be done I'm just trying to look
at you know what are the feature
correlations look like so I'll know what
to do with each of these features am I
going to delete some of them or what
what will I do with these
and just like quick Outlook of you know
like how our data labels look like it
seems like you know it might be a highly
imbalanced class problem because clearly
we don't have enough data points for all
of the classes for the quality of wine
and just a couple of utility functions
okay so here is where my experiment
actually starts right and for experiment
one I have like you know certain
conflicts that I want to run meaning I
want a standard scalar and PC it's just
a template example just to show you you
know for the purpose of the demo
and these are the configs that I'm going
to use and now I will create a new
Branch named experiment one
and let's go ahead and see that okay
again you can see that in just data and
experiment one have similar Point names
meaning I just created from them
and it only currently has the raw data
let's just save like you know dump our
configs the current configs that we have
for this experiment
and okay so we jump to the configs this
is how it looks
cool
and the next is let's go ahead and
create some features out of these data
columns that we have
and I'm I looked at the you know pair
plot of each of these features and I
somehow think you know because of the
pair plot some some of these features
are correlated for example acidity and
pH because they're all almost similar
and correlated so I went ahead with the
PCA just to see you know if do I need
all of them or I'll just pick
a top I guess six here because I'm okay
with the 90 variance explained
and
okay so let's just go ahead
so this is how my features look like now
I have like six of these components
so now I've written my features as well
and as you can see here this is how they
look
and now let's go ahead and train the
models you know to start with like
before that of course I wanted to split
them into the test and the train set and
then write them back as well because I
want to have the same test on the
training data to be able to reproduce my
experiment later
and so of course so when I run the
experiment I get about 64 percent
as my F1 score
mm-hmm
of course I'm not happy with it but I
would anyway go ahead and save my model
artifacts and the metrics
great
so we're done like you know running
experiment one we did like a almost you
know five six steps of you know how to
run that experiment and we committed at
each of these steps we have everything
captured and for experiment two
yeah okay so before we go into
experiment two another important thing I
wanted to show is about the lineage of
things for example now when you see oops
oh my God no
no
I really hope so okay not bad
all right so what I wanted to say was
here basically
when you do you know look at the the
final comment you will have the option
to go back to your parent comments right
so you you have a commit log of each of
the comments that you've done and the
commit logs are also accessible to you
programmatically you know from the API
so you would have like
depending on you know how however long
the process is like or the experiment
that you're running you will be able to
access all the way back to the raw data
meaning now you have the model and you
know what data and what features created
the model and then what are the configs
associated with the model and all the
way back to the raw data and the data
sources
and here I'm showing it in the UI you
know for the effects of it but you are
able to access this you know
programmatically as well and you can
play with it as you need
so yeah we went all the way back to when
the repository was created
and then again experiment two is kind of
similar I think I would quickly run
through this just with a different set
of configs and parameters just to make
sure it is different from experiment one
and hoping for a better results of
course
okay so another thing here I'm trying to
do is you know playing around with the
labels instead of having like you know
one to ten labels I'm just trying to
group them into good bad and okay
hoping it would help me with the
imbalance problem but it won't because
again it was normal distribution and
both of the ends would be you know
the long tails
but I'm just playing around with the
labels to see if it will help again with
my
FM score
[Music]
okay again so I guess we do get a better
Essence score compared to before
but now I'm just gonna
like you know save this model artifact
and the metrics of course
and I'm not going to try to forward it
this time
[Music]
okay so I do see that it is you know
better here and I go to my branches and
I will now try to compare the branches
you know like let's compare the
experiment one branch on the experiment
two branch of course for the
foreign
and you will be able to see the
difference
and in the end so I decide of course The
Experiment 2 is better because it gave
me better reference score now let me go
ahead and merge
I want to merge Experiment 2 into Main
so yeah
let's do that
I'm selecting
The Source wins because the source is my
Experiment 2 branch and I want to
overwrite it into my main
and that is it so if you go and look the
commit history of main of course it is
going to have all the comments from
The Experiment 2 branch which is now you
know added to your main like deployed
from experiment to Branch to your
production
now so another part of the demo is like
you know how do you actually reproduce a
specific experiment using lakefest tags
so for that I'm just gonna you know
Define a tag with your you know with
today's time stamp and go ahead and
check out the data and all of these
models and the artifacts from that
specific tag
and as you can see here when I try to
check out it the features look like
pca1026 which is what I had in my
experiment one
and as you can just go ahead with it
all I'm trying to show here is if I
check out the same set of models and
same set of data and try to you know use
the model on the data if I get the same
accuracy I'm not going to train it again
I'm just going to
like I you know show here
just you know open the joblip file from
our model uh artifacts prefix and then
see if it gives us the same metrics and
it does which was about 64 which we got
it from experiment one
[Music]
and if I check it with experiment one
it is the same of course
and experiment two of course had a
different number
cool so just by creating the tags which
is similar to git tags you're able to
check out a specific iteration or a
specific commit you know however old the
commit may be and reproduce the same
iteration of the experiment and that's
about it that's all I had for the demo
and lastly I wanted to like you know
make a shout out to the lakefest
community lakefest is an open source
project so if you have you know if you
are first of all interested in
contributing to the project you're
always welcome and we have a thriving
community of users and contributors from
these different companies who are
currently using lakefs as well for you
know different use cases and again since
it is an open source project if you
think there is the need for you know one
of your teams or companies that you
would want to check it out feel free to
give it a spin and then see how it goes
and if you have any questions or you
know anything at all about the use case
feel free to connect with me of course
and there is also a slack Community
where we discuss about you know the
challenges and the use cases and whatnot
so there is that a square
thank you so much for being wonderful
and also patient audience when the video
kind of got you know messed up but
that's great thanks everyone
thank you